Hey, this is jad.
We just wanted to throw in
an extra episode into our
feed and honor for a movie
that we're really excited about. But first
couple weeks ago, I, I
stepped in here and I, uh,
sort of laid out a challenge grant that
we'd gotten from the Tau Foundation.
And the deal was,
if you remember that if 700 of you guys
listening step forward agreed to kick in
$7 a month to support
the making of radio lab,
then the Tau Foundation would give
us 70 grand to help make the show.
So again, 700 people decided
to donate $7 a month.
We get 70 grand. That was the deal. All
right, so how did we do? How did you do
you crushed it. Just crushed it. Okay.
We needed 700 people. As of right now,
I think we're at somewhere
over 3000 you did so well.
We did so well.
The Tao Foundation just came back to us
and upped the ante full on stretch goal.
Because here's the thing,
3000 people is amazing,
but that is just a tiny percentage of
the people who actually listened to this
podcast. So their thinking is
let's capitalize on this momentum.
Get the other 99.9% involved.
So their new stretch goal is that they
have agreed to match any donation that
comes to radio lab right
now up to 10 grand.
So if you decide to make the
seven bucks a month deal,
that becomes $14 a month.
If you decide to do a one
time donation at 60 bucks,
that's now 120 tau, we'll match
it. And this, just as a reminder,
this is how we're able to do, you know,
the year long investigations in the
police shooting or the nuclear chain of
command, just to name the last three that
we've done. This is how we pay for it.
And this challenge grant
will allow us to go farther.
So if you're down,
go to radio lab.org/match or you can text
the word match to the number four six
nine eight six six. Again,
text the word matched to the number six
nine eight six six a little formal pop
up and you can donate in a
matter of seconds. And thank you.
All right, so tonight is the premiere
of a movie we're really excited about.
It's called the mortal life of
Henrietta lacks it stars, um,
a um, a an up and coming
actress. Maybe you heard her,
Oprah Winfrey and it is
based on the book of a very,
very dear friend Rebecca
Skloot bestselling book.
You'll be able to watch the sh the movie
in a couple of days on HBO a but in the
meantime we were just so proud of Rebecca
thrilled that this movie is getting
out to a wider audience because
everyone should know the story.
So in honor of that,
we're going to play for you a
documentary produced with Rebecca.
We worked on it for a few years with her
while she was sort of formulating the
book and it includes tape.
You won't hear anywhere else.
We can
move me closer to hello. Hello,
hello. And the story. Okay.
It's about a tumor that
expands and never stops.
Begins in 1950 a black woman in Baltimore
is in her bathroom and she discovers
pretty much all on her own. Did
she has cancer? Um, it's all,
it's a little bit of a mystery
how she initially knew this,
but she knew it was there.
[inaudible]
and not, she called it.
She had told to her cousins for a while
that she thought there was something
wrong with her, with her womb,
and she climbed into her bathroom and
she slid her fingers up inside of herself
and found this lump chapter one first.
She went into her local doctor [inaudible]
I happened to be and attending at
that time.
The guy she eventually ended up seeing
at Johns Hopkins University was this
fellow, Dr. Howard Jones. I'm 98
next month. That'll be 99. Wow.
So when she came in to see you,
can you tell me anything about what
she was like? Well, she was a a
uh, you didn't remember
anything? No, I really don't.
But you remember her tumor,
right? Well, absolutely.
I never saw anything
like it before or after
[inaudible]
and this didn't look like
a normal tumor. It was.
It was deep purple and
about as big as a quarter,
I'm sort of shiny or soft. That was
another thing about it on examination,
slightly raised and new touch that
you might think it was a red Jello.
There was something very
strange about the way it looks
[inaudible]
so doctors took a sample? Yeah.
So they would cut off these little
teeny tiny pieces and see Haley's small,
tiny bite or two, they would
take a piece, put it in a tube,
and one would go into the lab
for diagnosis. And in this case,
since it was Hopkins, they would take an
extra piece and give it to man name guy
too. So George Guy was a
researcher who worked at Hopkins.
He had a deal with the clinic that
anytime they got a patient with cervical
cancer, they'd give him a tiny piece of
the tumor. What he really wanted to do,
his main mission, actually, not
just his scientists everywhere,
we're trying to do this.
They wanted to find a way to grow human
cells outside of a human being in a
dish, in a dish. George Guy
had been trying to do this,
working on this for decades. And
why? Exactly. Um, it's sort of like,
it's sort of like having a
little tiny bit of a person in a,
in a lab that's detached from them so
that you can do whatever you want with
them. You know,
you can't bombard some person with a
bunch of drugs and just wait to see how
much they can tolerate before
their cells all explode.
But you can do that in cell
culture. So, oh, so this is like,
this is like the basic thing
you need to study human biology.
You need cells in a dish. Yes.
Problem was anytime they tried
to grow human cells in a dish,
my daughters, they would
die. Yeah, they died.
This is George Guy's former lab
assistant. Can you just tell me your name?
You know, my name is so
and so. My name is Mary.
I'll put my maiden name in there.
Oh sure. Toy Cooper cheque.
Mary lives just outside of Baltimore.
About an hour from where she used to
work with George guys. This is Dr. Guy.
Show me some pictures and he's sitting
at at a microscope. He looks, he's,
he seems like a really big guy, like
a really tall guy who was a big guy.
At least six, five judging
from the picture. Yeah, he was.
And in every slide that she showed me,
he had kind of a crazy smile on his face.
Like he's got a, like he's having
a good time. Bear of a man as well.
I always thought, oh yeah. In any case,
Mary says they were completely stumped
at why the human cells always died to us,
but they just did. Yeah. So on
the day that George Guy Walked in,
handed Mary a two with a little chunk
of a name was women cervical cancer
inside. I knew nothing about her.
No one expected anything. Oh,
he was doing well, he probably, yeah,
when I said ever hopeful, but you know,
I was eating lunch and I thought,
oh, the heck with it. You know,
it's not going to grow. I'm
going to finish the sandwich.
And that's what I did.
Three. Then I went in and
she gave the cells some food,
did my usual turn on all
the machines and left,
came back the next day they hadn't died,
so she came back the next day and they
were growing and then the next day still
growing. They just kept plugging along
in the neck. They grew a lot. RECA says
they doubled in size every 24 hours.
Yeah, they just grew. All
of a sudden, you know,
I kept transferring them and making
more tubes, transferring them,
making more tubes, transferring. They
weren't very reliable and stronger.
They just kept plugging
along and alone. Meanwhile,
the woman had spawned all
these cells die right?
Officially she died of uremia,
which is a like toxicity of the blood
because she wasn't able to get rid of the
toxic waste. That usually goes out in
your urine log in the log in the wall,
not herself,
and to tell us this story is a
privilege to introduce Dr. George Guy.
It wasn't long after the
George Guy appeared on TV
holding in his hand a little
bottle. Oh, let me show you a bottle,
like an alarm, which we have growling
quantity of catheter style.
So did you want to look at the photos
and you can't really get a sense of how
aggressive this tumor was until you go
to the Hopkins Archives and looked at
George guys pictures and
videos. Okay, this is it.
Come on Ken here to Healer
Cell Film than it hits you.
But you're there in a large
10,000 times. Oh my God.
Swirling hurricanes of cells,
just like thousands of people,
some nice small and some very large
together and kept transferring them and
making more to leave them
under the microscope.
Looks like something is just
exploded, like you're going to just
keeps getting bigger, bigger
and strong. It's indestructable,
it's indescribable. Nothing can stop it.
Why?
Hers just sort of took off and grew and
the other ones that they had tried it
didn't is just a little bit of a mystery
nobody really knows for and the less
George Guy knew what he had,
this new cell line was what they'd
all been waiting for. So early on,
right after this woman died,
George Guy sent Mary back down to get
more cancer cells from the [inaudible].
Oh, he sent me down to the
morgue. Yeah. Really? Oh yeah.
So I went down there and, um, the
a coroner, I don't know who he was.
Dr God was there too. And they were
standing down at her feet, sort of. Yeah.
Meanwhile, she's like, she's flying
out there. She's already opened.
I got some samples. Coroner would
take them out and give them to me.
What'd she look like? I couldn't look
at her face. I couldn't look at her.
The only thing I looked at were her toes
and they had chip nail Polish on them.
And that was really like,
oh, this is a real person.
What was it about the nail Polish that
hit you? Oh, cause it was chipped.
Cause you know that she hadn't been able
to take care of her nails for a long
time if they got chipped like that.
And it's showed that she
was proud of herself.
Not everyone wears nail Polish
on their toes. Yeah. Yeah.
Over the next several months
while this woman's body laid,
decomposing and the ground George Guy and
Mary produced hundreds of thousands of
herself or tumor cells and he
named them the heela strain.
Heela like Hella h e l a [inaudible].
No one would actually know why he had
named them that for about two decades.
Hmm. But what he did with these cells,
you know, we'd be unusual nowadays,
like if somebody now found
a cell that was special,
they'd run off to the patent office
and then sell it to Merck for 1 billion
bucks. But Georgia guy, hey,
just pass them out freely.
Didn't try and make any
money off. It was just
nice, nice new thing
that could help science.
Mary says that George Guy began to
send Hilo all over the world. Yeah.
And pretty soon she was in
hundreds of labs. And you know,
this was in the midst of
the polio epidemic season
when polio is at its worst,
we're talking early fifties right?
Yeah. So there's 1951 52 you know,
schools are being closed.
Kids are being kept inside
today's cruel disease. Medical
science still has no complete onset.
There was this enormous effort
to develop a polio vaccine.
Problem was in order to develop a vaccine,
you had to have enough polio virus,
you know enough quantity to be
able to study it in the lab.
And they had no way of making enough. So
whether they do, well, one of the guys,
that guy, one of the guys that
guy had sent the sales to,
this collaborator friend of guys
discovered something kind of amazing,
which was that polio loved the heela sell,
put polio inside a heela cell healer
would copy and in the process make more
polio. So which the Super Xerox
cell, no matter what you want to do,
they'll be like, make a copy,
make a copy, make a copy. Yeah.
So now they had a way of making polio
either could just be a polio factory and
so you government made a factory at
the Tuskegee Institute, a real one,
literally a factory. So they
had these big, you know,
stainless steel and have that sort of
culture medium that were sort of rotated
constantly autoclaves for
sterilizing all your equipment.
A row with four or five microscopes,
crazy frankensteinish gizmos.
They had this machine that was like an
automatic cell dispenser and it had this
orbit on mechanical arm in Squirt a
certain amount of this cultural medium
filled with Hilo cells into a two. Wow.
This is like the beauty of industry
right here. Yeah, it is. Absolutely.
The cells that were
produced at this factory,
she says were used to test
the polio vaccine back cleaned
the test that they were doing in Norris.
It was the largest field
trial ever done at its peak.
The tests [inaudible] he lived production
center was producing about 6 trillion
cells a week. Wow. Um, which
is kind of inconceivable,
but that was actually only
the beginning says Rebecca,
because this factory led to an even
bigger one. It was for profit. Right.
And that second factory was the first
time any human biological material was
commercialized. So this was the first
biotech company? Yeah, basically. Okay.
When they first started
mass producing healer, uh,
what sorts of things
were done to these sales?
What sorts of problems were investigated?
Like anything, I can imagine.
So they infected the Hilo cells with
every kind of virus, hepatitis E,
Coyne and encephalitis, virus, yellow
fever, herpes, measles, mumps, rabies,
whatever. You just any, any
back. And this was just as,
there's a revolution for scientists
and research on chemotherapy drugs.
He cells went up in some of the
first space missions. Really? Yeah.
So they were Vila went into space,
into space. And every time I hear it,
I think of it like Beulah.
Why? I mean,
just because the premise was to see what
happens to human cells in zero gravity.
You know,
if we're going to be sending people up
into space and what's going to happen to
them up there, they went up
before any humans did. Um,
and then she eventually went up his,
she the cells there was actually
interesting. A little slip up there. Yeah,
I know. Okay.
So let's actually skip forward in
the story to the point where that,
that slip up,
you just heard that pronoun
confusion gets personal,
you know. Well, what happened? Okay.
It's a late sixties and a heela has led
to a revolution in science and now there
are hundreds of cell lines,
not just he live at hundreds.
And somewhere along the way,
scientists discover that he lays so
aggressive that she's actually been
contaminating and taking over all of
these other cell lines where you just said
she, but I get your point and she,
she does it in the way it
does it in the strangest way.
Can you know they can float on
dust particles. They can write,
they can what? They can
float on dust particles.
Yeah. So they can, you mean
they can hop out of addition,
just get on a particle and
just float out the door.
Up the stairs. Down the hall one
he'll sell into lab rops into,
into dish or cell culture where there's
other cells growing and because he will
Selzer. So if powerful
cells they take over.
So on the heels of this catastrophe,
someone at Hopkins decides to make a test.
Let's make a test that will allow us
to genetically determine if a cell is
healer or if it is. And to
make a long story short,
this desire for a genetic test led
scientists and then journalists to ask a
question,
which amazingly for 25 years had not
been asked who was this woman and that's
when we found out her
name Henrietta lacks.
Yeah.
This is the sound of Rebecca
Reading Henrietta's medical records
the first time.
This is a 30 year old colored woman.
She's sitting with Henry
and his youngest daughter,
this is second November, so this is again
when she was pregnant with you. Right.
Henrietta had five kids when she died
at the age of 31 most have no memory of
her because they were too young.
That's especially true of Deborah was
only 15 months old and I don't remember
anything about my mother.
Yeah. So she, you know, she,
she had spent her entire life just sort
of longing to know who her mother was
and did she like dancing? You know,
I always wanted to know what she liked
to do when she went where she liked to
eat. Did she breastfeed? Debra? She,
she was really sort of
almost fixated on that idea.
She wanted to know if she was breastfed.
Oh, I don't know. You know, I don't
know what I would give up just to,
just to have her hair, hey,
just to see her in a whole her.
So in 1973 when a scientists
calls the lacks family,
and Deborah hears that little bits of
the mother that she never knew are still
alive. And oh by the way, can we take
a blood test from you and your family?
Cause we're having some contamination
problem. We need these genetic markers,
blah, blah, blah. Well, as you could
imagine, tell me about the prize.
It really did. It was really
confusing. I mean, how much is the,
how much of ourselves is out there?
You know, eventually she went online,
did some searches and found thousands
and thousands of hits. Like for instance,
on healer clones. And
Deborah had heard, you know,
various journalists in the past had
come to her and mentioned, you know,
dolly the clone sheep and
said, you know, your mom,
they did this with your mom too.
Meaning that's actually
where the technology started.
The first cells that ever
cloned were heela cells,
but that was just cloning a cell,
not cloning an entire being.
But that distinction is very complicated,
particularly for somebody who doesn't
know what a cell is. Yeah. Um, so Debra,
between what journalists had told her
and googling Henrietta lacks and clone
thought there were thousands of clones
of her mother around. And really,
you mean like a bunch of Henrietta's
walking street walking around.
And Rebecca says that one of Deborah's
biggest fears was bumping into one of
these clones. She said,
you know, she would say, I,
I would have to go talk to her and she
wouldn't know that I was her daughter
and, and, and I don't know
that I could handle that. Wow.
It sounds so fantastical.
Like how could someone believed that
there are copies of her mother walking
around, but at one point 25
years after their mother died,
someone called and said, Hey, part
of her is still alive and you know,
we've grown enough of her so that it
could wrap around the earth several times.
At that point, all bets are
off. Yeah, right, exactly. Yeah.
So,
not to mention that it's actually not
that crazy because your DNA is in your
cells. So if your cells are taken
out of you and they still grow,
well, isn't that still you alive?
It's of you, but it's clearly not you.
And in the end it's going on and on.
It's a funny middle space,
that's for sure. Yeah.
So here's what happened is Rebecca
went off in search of Henrietta lacks.
Every so often Debra would come along
and sit with her as they interviewed,
you know, anyone they could find friends,
family, and eventually over many,
many years, the picture does emerge
of who this woman was. She
was born in, in Roanoke,
1920 Virginia and I think she
was the 10th of the 11 children.
But apparently she was
the one that stood out.
Everybody talked about her as just
being, you know, she was the cat.
Oh my goodness. I don't
think I could top her.
This is CD Sturdivan Henrietta's
cousin, and it was a beautiful girl.
I was dating for myself, but
hint, it was very pretty brand.
Okay. And this is Henrietta sister,
Gladys Knight, and complacent.
Everyone that they spoke with
zeroed in on the same few points.
Like first she was really meticulous
about her nails, always painted them red.
It's very deep red and second
Henrietta just had this,
she was very strength
forthright, very Sassy,
Mike herself. Now the unfortunate thing
is that when it comes to her life,
you know how she lived. There's
not a ton of detail. Right?
Totally. So this is when she
first went in with your cancer,
but in that hotel room,
when the two of them,
we're flipping through the
medical records, they did
start to get some detail.
Okay, here's her autopsy,
right about how she died.
These are the things I
want to take notes about.
Was she in a lot of pain when she
died? Yeah, this was the hardest thing.
She was eventually in an
unbelievable amount. Yeah.
Pain, complains of pain in
the right lower quadrant,
wailing and crying and you
know, moaning for the Lord,
the helper and according to the records,
doctors tried everything. Morphine,
they injected a hundred percent
alcohol straight into her spine.
Wow. I knew the pain spider,
the alcohol injection last week.
She would have these fits of pain
[inaudible]
to spasms where this waves of pain would
hit her and she would rise up out of
the bed and thrash around. So
they strapped it to the bed.
And for sister, um, we, along
with one of her friends,
you know,
one of them would tighten the straps and
the other one would put a pillow in her
mouth so that she wouldn't bite her tongue
if I only just had the
chair. So take care of her
now dealing with how her
mother died was one thing,
but the cells made it more
complicated. Whatever parent,
her mother was alive in these
cells somehow. So if that's true,
that left very big questions. And
the first of them for Deborah was,
how can Henrietta rest in peace if part
of her with part of her soul is being,
you know,
shot up to the moon and injected with
all these chemicals in a radiated and
bombarded,
painful. No one, you know,
that had her shells on the back
of a donkey going to Turkey,
you know, and the airplanes
just going all over the world.
Uh, uh, I just don't know.
Is she worried about them? She
worried that it hurts her mother.
When you infect the cells with Ebola,
does somehow her mother feel the pain
that comes with Ebola and had a scientist
ever like sat down with her and yeah,
I mean just explained to
her like this is no, never,
nothing cause it's spy.
It just strikes me that it wouldn't
be that hard to explain it.
Like when you take cells out of a body,
it's Kinda like when you cut your
fingernail off it just doesn't,
but your fingernail doesn't keep
growing and living after you cut it off.
It's a, it's really hard.
There is no other example of some way
that you can take something from someone's
body and have it keep living
and not have a person feel it
and all these worries says her Baga began
to build and Deborah's mind and build
and build
there came at this point. So
we were at her cousin's house.
This is her cousin Gary.
She was broken out in hives and she was
telling him all this stuff that she'd
recently learned. You can almost
hear it on the tape. She says to him,
when you get off the leaders there,
she can't carry the burden of
these cells anymore. She can't.
Okay. I don't want to [inaudible]
and I had been started trying to talk
her down and he was trying to talk her
down
[inaudible]
and then just out of
nowhere he just started
singing
[inaudible] Yo
[inaudible]
Ooh. Gebo
[inaudible] I know those [inaudible]
and he started preaching
thing that doctors came,
that he held her head in his
hands and we come to you tonight,
the offer then the finish of our faith.
And we thank you for being a wait mic.
You make a path in the the middle.
You called the mountains of
skip leg rams and healed.
We thank you today. Thank
you all. Thank you for it.
Thank you though. Thank you. Thank you.
[inaudible] hello? Hello? Hello? Yeah.
[inaudible] great,
great.
And she just relaxed
know like him man. Huh?
I feel like, Huh?
She didn't realize it then, but that
night Debra was on the verge of a stroke
one to walk up into the building
one wall. Okay. You mean?
He said it's just [inaudible].
One of the most striking moments of
this story is when the two of them
visit hospitality. Feel Fun. Yeah. Yeah.
Deborah meets her mother's
cells for the first time.
I shouldn't have, I'll show you that
room and I can show you that itself
because the scientists had finally
contacted her, Christophe Lynn Gower,
the scientist who invited us
into his lab to see the cells.
He had projected them onto a screen.
Don't be confused. They look green here.
This is exactly what she always
dreamed of. But then just last year,
something interesting happens. Interesting
and troubling. So yeah. So March,
2013 this group of scientists from Germany
sequenced the genome and publish it
online where anyone can download it. You
just click a button. I downloaded it.
It was just there and they
did not ask the family. Um,
and my initial reaction when I saw
this press coverage was they did what?
Because within the Hilo genome there is
also Henrietta's genome and some of that
was pet.
50% of that was passed under her kids
and 25% potentially her grandkids.
But one of the things, so when
they put out a press release,
when this genome was sequenced and
on it, it had a little, you know,
frequently asked questions of the press
might wander about and one of them was
can you learn anything about Henrietta
or her or her children from this genome?
And the answer was no, you
can't learn anything about them.
And I do and I believe that
they, that they believe this,
but this is a misconception. You
can in fact learn about people.
And in fact you cannot even hide
people's private information if you try.
And so one researcher took the genome
and created essentially a report on Henry
at his genes,
you have x percent chance
of bipolar disorder,
alcoholism,
obesity just has this
huge range of things.
And some of it is, yes,
there's some real potential privacy
violation like with the Alzheimer's genes
and things like that. Bits of
information about your family.
But I will not tell you
what this report that
this dude May, right.
Did he list all of these things you're
describing? And he sent it to me.
So I called the waxes and said, do
you know, did you know that this,
anything about this? And Rebecca
had called, you know, they did not.
And it kind of bothered us
because we're saying, okay,
why wasn't a family involved with this
decision making? That was Jerry lax.
Jerry lacks why Henrietta lacks
his granddaughter back in the 50s,
you had him Riata lacks her cells were
removed without her family's knowledge.
Then you go in the 70s,
my dad and his siblings,
um, they took blood samples,
used it for research.
They didn't give consent.
Then you come 2013 and you have Henrietta
is that I felt as though it was her
medical records being published publicly.
You know, their first question was,
can you get them to take it down?
And so we can figure out
what it is, what it means.
So I reached out to the scientists
and said, the lacks family, you know,
has asked that you take this down.
And they replied immediately.
They took it offline immediately. And
then I contacted, um, Francis Collins,
who's the head of the NIH.
I also reached out to Kathy Hudson who
used to run the genetics and public
policy center at Hopkins and is now over
at the NIH dealing with a lot of these
issues. So I reached out to them and said,
somebody needs to try to just
help the maximum and get consent.
Somebody needs to just go back,
pretend like this is starting now and
just do what probably should have happened
in the first place.
NSA might've been like a
couple of weeks after that,
several weeks after that that we had
a meeting with NIH and it was my mom,
myself, my sister, my dad, my uncle,
my brother David, my sister Kim,
my cousin Ron, Rebecca Skloot. She
was actually on a conference call.
All the NIH folks drove up to Baltimore.
We Google their names, Dr. Collins and
candy. I said, and it was like, oh,
we weren't cutting. He was
excited. Like, okay. Yeah.
We sitting in a room with the director,
they all met just to listen to everybody,
you know, listen to our concerns,
listen to our questions, what
can be done, what can't be done.
The lacks family asked about
everything you could possibly imagine
when over, you know the information
about Gino gene mapping, sequencing,
just the basic science of genome
to get a,
a clear understanding of
what the Geno met to science.
We don't want to stop science but yet
we don't want certain information to be
just broadly available publicly.
So the laid out three options. One was
we don't release any of them at all.
And then there was a second option which
was release it with no restrictions,
just put it out there
like the Germans did.
And then there was a third option
which was release it with restrictions.
So the NIH would house it on their own
servers and that in order to get access
to it, you would have to send
in an application at said,
this is the research we're going to do.
There would be a committee formed that
was a group of scientists and the some
members of the lacks family,
the Hilo Gino Committee,
one grands child and one great grandchild.
My brother David and my
cousin Veronica. And yeah,
this is the option they picked. So, yeah,
there's this committee and they just,
um,
a few weeks ago saw their first batch of
applications and then the news hit and
it was the first time that they
were part of the news. So they,
the third generation, the lacks family,
like Jerry lacks was on MSNBC live
doing an interview about this. And like,
she, you know, she'd never
done this before and you know,
they were in every newspaper.
I mean, it was everywhere.
Yeah. It's pretty exciting. Yeah.
We are stepping into the spotlight.
It's the grandchildren, the third
and fourth generation of waxes.
It's the great grandchildren. This is
their story now. And that's, you know,
the other thing that is an undercurrent
where all this is Deborah is gone.
She was the one who was just so forceful
and so dedicated with getting the
information out there about her mom.
And you know, when I look at the four
years since the book came out, you know,
there are a few moments that stand out
as incredibly emotional ones for me
having to do with Deborah. But this,
the first meeting sitting
on this speaker phone,
listening to this meeting,
these high officials sitting at the
table and in pay of sincere concern about
our questions. If she
could have said, what?
What do I dream might someday happen?
That would be what she
would have described.
[inaudible] I could just imagine her
just sitting there and then she had just
laughing, rocking back and forth,
twiddling her talk on them,
her finger saying, Yay,
just I'm absorbing all
of this, this excitement.
[inaudible]
before we close, I want to thank Rebecca
Skloot for giving us her raw tapes.
Her book, the mortal life of
Henrietta lacks is truly spellbinding.
You can get more information@radiolab.org
sign up for our podcast there.
radiolab.org.